الى سوريا حيث خرجت مظاهرات في شمال
السوري ترفض اي مصالحه مع نظام الاسد
وتؤكد على ثواب الثوره في المقابل قال
وزير الدفاع التركي ان بلاده ابلغت موسكو
ودمشق بعدم قدرتها على تحمل موجه جديده من
اللاجئين من سوريا للمتابعه ينضم الينا من
مدينه الباب بريف حلب مراسل الجزيره عمر
حوراني كما ينضم الينا من انقر مراسل ال
الجزيره المعتز بالله حسن اهلا بكما وابدا
مع عمر حوراني
وممكن ان تلخص لنا ابرز الشعارات التي
طرحت في هذه المظاهرات وايضا عن همم
اعدادها ومناطقها
نعم عبد السلام مازلنا في مدينه الباب حيث
خرجت مظاهره كبرى وهناك قرابه 30 نقطه
تظاهر هنا في عدد من مدن وبلدات ريف حلب
وايضا في مدينه ادلب وريفها ايضا خرجت
مظاهره في محافظه درعا جنوبيه سوريا وعلى
مستوى اللاجئين كان هناك في امستردام في
هولندا مظاهره وجميع هذه المظاهرات خرجت
تحت اسم لن يصالح في اشاره من المتظاهرين
الى انهم يرفضوا اي تقارب مع النظام
السوري وانهم لديهم مطالبهم حتى يتم حديث
عن همم عن مفاوضاتهم والمتظاهرين هنا
قالوا بانه اي حل اا يجب ان يكون بعد رحيل
الاسد وان الحلول يجب ان تكون ضمن نصت
عليه همم
الاتفاقيات الامميه والاسيه والقرار الامم
22/04 54 المظاهرات اذا كما تحدثنا هنا
كانت في عموم الشمال السوري وهنا في
الشمال السوري معظم السكان هم من النازحين
وهنا كان هناك اشاره همم
للمتظاهرين بانهم قالوا بان هذا النظام
الذي يتقارب منه بعد تتقرب منه بعض الدول
هو النظام الذي هجرهم من مدنهم من
محافظاتهم هنا الى الشمال السوري ويقولون
بان هذا النظام قد ارتكب جرائم وقتل
الكثير منهم وايضا هو من يعتقل حتى الان
مئات الالاف من السوريين وهو يرفض اخراج
هؤلاء معتقلين من سجونه وانه ايضا اين
ايضا يماطل في الحلول السياسيه السياسيه
في همم مبادره جنب او الستانه او حتى
مبادره اللجنه الدستوريه فهو لم ياتي باي
تقدم في هذه المبادرات وانه ايضا يصير على
ما هو عليه وهمم المتظاهرون قالوا بانه
ايضا لا يوجد به جعبه النظام اي شيء يقدمه
لهم فهم على الرغم من انهم يعيشوا حياه
فقر هنا في شمال سوريا الا ان المناطق
التي يسيطر عليها النظام هي تعيش فقر اكبر
والنظام لا يستطيع ان يقدم شيء لمناطق
التي يسكنها يعني المناطق التي يسيطر
عليها اليك نعم عمر وسنبقى في متابعه
المشهد ماذا عن الموقف التركي ربما نذهب
المعتز بالله حسن وزير الدفاع التركي
خلوصي اكار في الفتره الاخيره كان يضع
النقاط على الحروف فيما يتعلق بالمخاوف
همم التركيه مما يجري في الشمال السوري
صحيح يا عبد السلام خلال السنوات والشهور
الماضيه كان هناك انتقاد واضح من المعارض
التركيه للحكومه التركيه والرئيس اردوغان
بتباع سياسه خاطئه في سوريا واغراقي
وتركيا بحسب وصف المعارضه التركيه
باللاجئين السوريين وعدم الحديث
مع دمشق وبالتالي هذه في ظل بعد هذه
الانتقادات ومناطق اقتراب الانتخابات هناك
او تغير واضح في الحديث التركي تجاه
العلاقه مع دمشق خصوصا وان العلاقات كانت
على مستوى الاستخبارات بين الجانبين
واتحدث وزير الدفاع قبل ايام عندما قال ان
هناك همم قد يكون همم رفع لهذا المستوى
وبعدها شهيدنا اللقاء الذي حصل في موسكو
ويوم امس تحديدا كان ايضا هناك حديث
للرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان عن ان هناك
من الممكن الانتقال الى سوريه جديده من
اللقاءات مع دمشق في حال تم الاستجابه
لبعض المطالب التركيه وبالتالي التحرك
التركي الان هو بحسب همم من يتابع هذا
الملف هنا في تركيا هو من اجل حمايه
متابعه حمايه المصالح التركيه وخصوصا ان
هناك تاكيد من انقره على ان على انها حتى
في هذه المفاوضات وحتى في هذه الخطوه
الجديده التي وصلت اليها هي ترفض تماما ان
يكون هناك اي تهديد امني على حدودها اليوم
وزير الدفاع التركي اعاده تاكيد على هاتين
ان نقطتين وقال ان تركيا همم ترفض ان يكون
هناك اي تهديد امني همم من شمال سوريا
لحدودها ولامها وايضا انها ترفض ان همم
يستمر اغراق تركيا
وانها ليست مستعده لاي موجه جديده من
اللاجئين كان هذا في حديث لوزير الدفاع
التركي عبد السلام دعنا نستمع لما قال
اعربنا بوضوح الموقفنا باننا لن نتهاون
ابدا في مكافحه الارهاب وانه ليس لدينا
هدف غير مكافحه الارهاب كما هو معلوم يوجد
في بلدنا ما يقارب 4 ملايين لاجئ سوري
ووفقا للشروط الحاليه في بلدنا وبنيتها
فاننا لا يمكننا تحمل لاجئين جدد وانه لا
يمكننا القبول بموجه اللجوء جديده لذلك
فان ما نقوم به من فعاليات هدفوا هذا مانو
بقايا شقائنا السوريين في مناطقهم
شكرا الزميلين المعتز بالله حسن كان معنا
من انقره كما نشكر عمر حوراني من مدينه
الباب في حلب